all right let's do it episode 150 baby
and welcome to the trash toast award pop
yeah and then we'll be like
practice this in your minds you got it
one take we've only got one take we've
got one thing we've only got one very
very expensive are you gonna like Let It
Fly or wow probably not I don't know how
to do that
you just [__] oh yeah I'll do that
sure oh my God
welcome to the trash taste Awards
[Music]
you [__] it off I lightly tapped it
how did it come out the trash days
Awards is already ruined let's go clown
dog
I got it I got it one day guys one thing
that's that's all I needed I lightly
touched it and it just jumped out
holy [__] where did that go yeah but
like did it jump up yeah oh yeah it hit
the ceiling it like smashed into the
ceiling
that was a good start of course Connor
was going to be the one to do that JoJo
suit man of course Connor starting off
this trash case Awards by uh throwing
once again uh he choked on just opening
a bottle of champagne at the right time
that's not my fault all right I got gun
dirty I'm so glad the cameras were
rolling holy [__] that [__] shoot of
champagne what would you want some man
yes please thank you let's go let's go
baby three years three years boys
production assistant is just cleaning up
my mess oh you're giving me a [__]
glass of bubbles what the [__] is that
what is this head this is the head
episode
did you learn this from John PA the
third yeah his father gave me this I
didn't do me properly actually wow right
you know okay
[Music]
well ladies and gentlemen it is episode
150 which means it is the annual trash
taste Awards three years ladies and
gentlemen we've been going at it for
three years now I do have something a
little bit awkward to say uh because you
know we we it's you know we chose 50 the
first year because it was a nice round
number yeah and at that point we've
taken like two weeks off for like I
believe our drifting special and our
um cycling special uh but now that we
kind of upload specials in the middle of
the week uh we don't take a break any
week for trash taste so it's actually
like two weeks from being a year yeah
technically technically technically but
why did you say that because now people
are going to be like oh looking forward
to the next crash taste Awards in
episode 204. so so yes like in about
five years or something we're gonna have
like 10 episodes behind or something
like that and it's gonna be like half a
year gone it doesn't matter we're only
thinking about the third year
[Applause]
so if you aren't familiar with the trash
taste Awards which you probably are if
you're watching episode 150 it's the
yearly recap of all the best moments of
the show the past year from the specials
to the stuff off camera a little bit and
just the highlights of all the episodes
yeah and so we have made some new
categories previously we had many
categories but we've added some little
fun new ones taken out some some it
didn't really didn't hit as hard as we
liked and we're just going to go through
all the moments and talk about the Year
this is great I love the trash days
Awards because I actually get reminded
of all the dumb and weird [__] we said
we did because yeah for me and I
remember any of them we say a lot of
[__] and it's especially during the
nomination stage where we go through it
and uh we kind of realize oh who said
that so many moments where one of us is
late did I say that did I say that I
don't feel like I said that but also the
the clips right there yeah I guess I did
say that yeah you know what guys
probably deep faked right we we would
have no idea AI generated this is AI
generated but yeah this year we have to
chose categories that best encapsulated
everything and all the moments that
happened in this year and I feel like
this year was the year that was
encapsulated by us kind of like
traveling around a lot you know
the first two years we were definitely
just stuck in Japan and we tried to make
as much content from Japan as possible
but doesn't it feel [__] insane
thinking back that this is the year that
we kind of got to meet a lot of like
other fellow content creators who we
like respected for like the longest time
and uh we kind of realized how much
trash taste had grown this year
especially during our La trip I remember
uh like way during like the first couple
of weeks we were like oh yeah this
little podcast maybe last like 30
episodes yeah it'll just dip like all
the other ones look at us 150 baby
that's way too many episodes
we're somehow good at being consistent
but we're also very inconsistent with
after doc this year we did way less
after dogs but that's you know not from
a lack of trying we're just all over the
place traveling we're all doing our own
things too so it's kind of hard to line
it all up but trash takes is nailed
every week though yeah thank God we
still haven't missed an episode we still
have not missed an episode in three
years and counting you know what I'll
give myself a medal for that that's
that's impressive no season breaks we
just we're back to back every single
week oh yeah I don't know how we've done
it I feel like there's been some close
calls we were like we have two days to
get an episode out yeah we didn't have
one so yeah we go man yeah we uh just
landed in La we have two days we have no
equipment and we have nothing to add
what the [__] are we going to do yeah
and somehow we still managed to get an
episode out and not miss a week yeah
yeah it's uh I think it's been a very
very busy year for all three of us on
trash days and outside of trash taste as
well so I think some of the awards and
nominations don't just represent stuff
that has happened on like let's say our
personal trash taste challenge but stuff
that's happened in the wider trash taste
Universe yeah the TCU whatever the TC
the ttcu the ttcu whatever you want to
call it you know I like how we have kind
of a match this weird kind of like
sitcom Vibe with any people who come on
you know we always refer to mailing and
then he's like what do you guys say
about me
so uh just a list of the categories
really quickly we have the hottest take
of the year of course well we're
starting things
best out of context clip screen grab of
the year most a general moment US state
we will not revisit that's a new one
uh saltiest moment most monkey moment
yes wildest guest episode because we
definitely had a lot of those uh best
story biggest clown biggest Chad all
caps biggest W of the Year very few to
count uh best nickname best meme best
Deez Nuts moment because uh I feel there
was like a Renaissance of Deez Nuts
jokes yeah yeah uh best strip best
argument most wholesome moment most
privileged moment biggest I made it the
[__] up moment best after dark moment
and of course the best trash taste
episode yeah so this is a pretty stacked
Awards and I feel like this encompasses
everything that happened this year yeah
so shall we get right on it let's just
jump right here
the hardest take of the year now when
you start as you know trash taste is
famous for a lot of our hot takes uh
controversial takes uh and uh often we
don't know what's gonna become an actual
hot take until the episode airs because
we just say [__] do you ever have that
feeling uh when we're recording when you
say something like oh that's not gonna
go down well you know and then it
doesn't I think you say something
completely normal you're like why do
they hate me for this yeah I think I
think that I think the more the hot
takes that have been birthed were the
ones where it didn't start off with I
know this is a hot take but it just ends
up not being a hot day and then just
something you're just like yeah I think
of this I don't know I had I had a few
this year where I'm like I know it's all
my opinion but I'm like I know this is
going to be a hotel there is there are
some things I feel like the audience
takes turn bagging on us they'll have a
month or it's like let's [__] on Joey's
opinions and then it's gone and then
it's me and then they just take it and
turn it they're like all right now I'm
thinking dance takes not that good
anymore it's a great antagonist every
single yeah
there's some there's always some hot
tape let's go through the nominations
yeah
so this year we had oranges are the
worst flavor known to mankind orange is
the worst flavoring known to men I think
orange is like orange what which I
believe is the exact quote that kind of
said you know do you know what's weird I
literally you said this so long ago I
literally thought this was last year
well this is gonna happen a lot I think
this awards that where we confused last
year and the sugars were in the same set
yeah yeah so I think that's like a hard
way to memorize it yeah um but yeah I
did say this I stand by my opinion yeah
orange is the worst flavor known to
mankind I'll be pissed off if this went
uh we also got uh a guest one which is
Emily taking the meat out of her arm
that's [__] up what the [__] I was
like is this what is that racism if I
get Ramen I take out the meat
what do you mean the big difference this
year is that because we had so many
guest episodes we could actually bring
in what our guests have said on our
podcast as well so we're sharing we're
sharing the hot takes between everyone
it's not just not just the three boys uh
We've also got uh I'm not I'm not proud
of this one ever Ava is not a Mecca
anime by Yours Truly Ava for me is
really weird because it's like at first
glance it tries to present itself as a
Mecca yeah but then the further you go
along you realize it's not a Mecca it's
just a [__] sci-fi I just I can't
believe you just said this I remember
the exact moment this was happening
because we were in a heated argument
about whether Attack on Titan uh is a
Mecca anime or not uh then out of
nowhere like you just drop this
bombshell yeah and I don't know where
this came from this is you know this is
one of those things where it sounded
great in my head and then the moment it
came out of my mouth my brain just went
you [__] why did you say
opinion of God preferring the latest
seasons of Game of Thrones
[Music]
I prefer the later seasons of Game of
Thrones [__] oh God genuinely
do you know what sometimes I say some
takes that I know are going to be hot
takes I don't even think this is like my
hottest take of the year but like it
surprised me the [__] reaction I got
for this take just because I it's it is
that [__] I don't think it is
I've never even I've never even seen
Game of Thrones and I know what I should
take I'm hoping that you know because
mine is very easy to have a stance on
oranges but maybe if you haven't seen
Game of Thrones you might not give a
[__] about mistakes there isn't a I I
don't think there's a person who hasn't
had an orange I'm hoping that people
will hate God's opinion so much that
they will outnumber the people who care
about oranges guy is this do we have
only four nominations for this one okay
we have more nominations all right all
right we have another slide okay so we
also have a couple more uh God using
light mode you dark mode [__]
play [__] up too much okay hi I'm I'm a
live mode user yes I'm I'm outing myself
right now okay
of course this is bad of course I knew
this was going to be a hot take this
wasn't surprising but you know what I
still use light mode look look let me go
let me go on Twitter right now guys let
me let me go
there we go let me let me let me go on
YouTube okay there we go there we go
have you had a question why you have
[__] eyesight it's probably because of
that yeah I need this to give me like to
find you make me see things better
honestly honestly it's I need light mode
I need live all pastries are bred by
Joey yeah uh I don't even remember
seeing this to be honest fair enough and
uh all sports are the same oh my God
I mean it is it is good it is good well
what's what's the difference I mean like
I know the difference but like it's not
the same concept with football
[Music]
I mean it's not that far off let's be
honest here you know what I hope that
one wins all right all right well we
have some really strong contenders right
off the bat all right there's some
terrible takes but which one did you
vote as the hottest aka the worst or
shittiest take of the Year what's your
money on boys what do you thinking I'm
thinking it's either going to be the
orange one I want it to be the orange
one I have wanted to be Sydney or Game
of Thrones yeah
I have a feeling it's between orange
Game of Thrones
um
yeah yeah yeah let's find out
and the winner is
oranges are the worst
wait
is there a tie on this one
this has never happened before to tie
with God I'm using light mode
wait wait what was that wait what was
the breakdown [__] 20 for the top two
holy [__]
okay oh my God
preferring the latest Seasons
[Music]
okay okay proven I have the best takes
on trash tastes for this year
the best taste this year listen to me
more okay
I'm surprised about the light mode one
because I'm not are you are you not no
because like it's like same thing with
oranges right like there isn't a single
person or there's very few people who
don't have you know mobile phones
nowadays right especially smartphones
and it's just like a common meme on the
internet now that light mode is [__]
[Music]
I'm wondering what oranges did to hurt
Conor as a kid because I've never it
just tastes bad I just never seen
someone so eminently hate oranges like
Hannah hates oranges more than like some
like atrocious things that happen
there's a lot of things to hate in the
world yeah you chose orange
is just so bad on artificial oranges are
bad you're not allowed anymore you got
the worst take I was very happy to be in
Florida and to tell them that oranges
suck
all right what's the next category
moving on we have best out of context oh
yeah I love this one
so God apparently said Chinese food
doesn't exist okay here's the thing I
don't think Chinese food exists right in
the sense
bro let me finish my points every
[__] finish my point I can't believe
you do me like that
I love the air quotations
trying to tell me this Chinese food
exists I've never seen it what I love
about that is just the pause before Joey
just processing what I said just just
like
no no hear me out hear me oh God
first of all Luffy is a terrorist
I'm here he is I I remember how like
just out of left field that line was I
mean yeah I was just like that is the
most Hassan thing that he's ever said on
this podcast and you know what he's
Hassan can see he's completely there
won't there ain't no cap in that line
man it was completely right now we're
talking about you oh this is my [__]
face wait what this is my favorite I
don't remember this I really hope this
wins when I was making uranium glass I
really want to be careful
that's such a good sentence
so what I remember about this that stood
out to me uh because there was a lot of
this conversation that stood out to me
but one thing I remember vividly was uh
shouting or Nigel for being like you
don't know where you got the uranium
from the uranium
because he was like I don't remember
where I got the uranium from
you said I got it from an undisclosed
address
that's a that's that he's been trained
yeah yeah here's what to say yeah he
does so he does uh I think this is
Connor saying this he said your your
anus was creamy and I don't know if I
was prepared for that
I love this whole exchange it was just
asking to be made you're really
screaming
I don't know
[Laughter]
that's a good screenshot of Joe he looks
horrible this is the one the shindo
element oh is it this last one this is
this is when Joey's third eye opens this
is me like realizing the truth of the
world right here uh is shindo L saying
what's not vanilla about birth it was
how is birth not vanilla though
you have to ask what what's happened to
make you think that like birth in
pornography is vanilla he's seen some
[__] no no he hasn't seen some [__] he
made this [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean like he is the guy who makes you
say you feel [__]
I think we've had an episode where I
think we've been so concerned with the
stuff that we said we're like we should
cut this and get rid of this yeah a lot
that didn't make it into that episode
yeah God my favorite part of that clip
is just Joey reaching Enlightenment in
that single line he's just like I have
found never I have found the promised
land I see everything now tags dojin
they're all the same I just didn't
realize you can ask that question and
not explode you know like I'm like oh my
god did you really just ask that I have
no idea what's going to win this one
honestly all these girls like all of
them I like all of them I I wish there
was a better like shorter clip for like
the null uh now of red conversation but
it's hard to there were so many little
moments of like what the [__] yeah all
of his episodes I mean all of that
episode was just not Nigel says alive
yeah and we're like what the [__] did
you just say yo yo yo go back go back
it's great because sometimes when you
have guests on and they say like they
just they explain in great detail about
everything they do but they don't
realize that this [__] is insane to
anyway you can't do it and he's great
because he's just going off oh yeah
you're like this is insane what is this
what am I like what am I what are we
listening to here no no we did not all
play with fire and batteries as a kid we
don't procure your meaning but not every
kid did this we didn't almost set a
school on fire you know we didn't mean
like chlorine gas in our free time
growing up this is not normal okay oh
man I really want the Nigel one to win
but also I just love that shindo clip as
well
Uranus clip as well yeah they're all
good all right but there can only be one
winner let them know I'm the winner for
the best out of context clip is
Luffy is a terrorist
I wonder if there's a bit of recency
bias but also maybe maybe
congratulations congratulations out of
context clip although honestly not that
much more context to it oh yeah it just
makes me think yeah
yeah amazing
it's it's kind of like what this line
reminds me of is remember like the hits
blunt meme from like [__] years ago
it's just like hits blunt Luffy is a
terrorist
that can apply to anything that could
apply to the loss
all right well what's the breakdown okay
Chinese food
all right almost three took most of the
votes all right all right all right you
know what was uh congratulations
congrats all right the next one next one
is screen grabbing of the Year oh my God
now there are a lot of screen Gap grabs
Jabs gaps uh from either trash taste
episodes or stuff we got to off camera
and uh on our own personal [__] as well
uh so let's have a look at what the
nominations are this year
[Music]
the truck I don't think this one is from
this year but I think it got more
popular this year yeah yeah I guess that
kind of God you look hideous in that
yeah that was Chris did me dirty in
there uh that's super super golf Bros
what's happening here oh that was I was
teaching Connor how to uh golf correctly
you guys are like Jordan and gold
experience
I love how it's all stretched out yeah
why is it stretched out uh POV you show
your cousin domestic girlfriend at the
same time
yeah yeah that was from the uh jessups
episode uh anymore yeah we got some more
I believe
as me holding a Tango uh no explanation
there yeah Conor and pewdiepiece why did
Ludwig uh remove his like oh because he
had because he had like a tattoo on his
leg right yeah
okay but he but he didn't say he had a
tattoo on his leg and he just saw
stripping did you know it's bad I
obviously remember recording that
episode but I did not remember this
happening until I saw out of context
screenshots and I'm like did that happen
on the episode I feel like I felt like I
would remember that
uh and I I loved the bottom right one as
well yeah
it's so perfectly your skin tone yeah
it's insane oh the bodysuit the bodysuit
also the bottom left one as well
that is just that is just a trash taste
episode like in a nutshell you know
for me let's go back to the truck it's
got to be trucker the [__] with the
weak chin man the weekend it's gonna be
the weekend
it has to be that way that is a world
compression did me dirty
in the only spot where it could make me
look [__] weird anywhere else would
have been fine it's a combination of
like the the weak shin and just the
tracker outfit
the position you're in as well well I
guess we'll find out let's find out he's
the winner of the best screen grab of
the Year all right winner of the best
screen grab of the Year 2023 is
chocolate
leafy chin Corner let's go look at all
the comments to f as well
that went by a lot yeah I want to know
how big this one boy
is shocking 39. 39
holy [__] [__] it no the biggest win the
biggest W so far half nearly half the
people voted for that yeah yeah second
place too much uh before Cycles oh my
God
what that's a massive discrepancy and
then third place
[Applause]
all right next one all right the most
degenerate moments wow degeneracy is a
normal thing on the trash taste podcast
it runs through the blot it does it does
uh and I think this has been an award
every year so far because there has
never been a year when there's not been
some degenerate [__] [__] happens
because I I don't even think I looked at
the the nominations
all this is like we said that yeah all
right let's find out let's go through
nominations the more of you Sleepless A
Midsummer Night stream
I want to wipe that from my memory man
that no fun with the with the pp with
the tapioca
if you if you know you know if you don't
know congratulations yeah that whole
episode
just gave me a curse man that was that
was so curse that's that's when that's
what we went too far I think and then we
also got our boy shinderella making a
planet of the ape sturgeon which uh I'm
disappointed because I haven't seen it
yet I really want to read it everything
that man does is like okay but why like
just because you could doesn't mean you
should second if no one needed the
Planet of the Apes don't you I couldn't
get over that in the episode I was like
what what someone asked for it no one
asked though that's the thing it's like
he was like anybody want it no no I'm
gonna make it yeah it's surprising that
in the entire episode we had to pick one
moment because I kind of just want to
put that in just shinderell himself as
like the most degenerate moment
absolutely of trash taste because that's
what my vote would go to uh and then
there's the boys want to read over here
or I guess it's me explaining read over
here yeah we we had two explanation
videos here so we had Joey explains his
redo of healer to saikuno and Ghana
explains domestic girlfriend to psychino
as well which uh I have which one's more
degenerate uh psychino hasn't like dm'd
me back ever since we recorded that
episode so he's just like straight up
yeah yeah it's like a no man I'm I'm
sorry I swear to God domestic girlfriend
just sounds so degenerate like it's like
when you it's because it is you're like
God damn it like I'm a sad person I've
been watching this
because it's fun yeah yeah it's it's
good it's good I'm not gonna start again
I don't want to hear it I've done that
enough I've done it enough uh the major
restoration led to hentai censorship in
Japan oh yes he's writing about how uh
right now ranting about Harry was
unhappy that the pawn was censored yeah
yeah he was going on
and he was we had an entire history
lesson of Japan uh that started from the
Meiji restoration that led to like Meiji
restoration means pixelated dick and
vagina in Japan only reason why it
happened
nothing good came out her parents to a
girl's file that's pretty degenerate
that is pretty generous but not as a
generous love-wing masturbating 18 times
in one day I completely forgot I don't
believe it yeah I don't believe him no
no that's fine yeah he's like there's no
way there's no way absolutely no way I I
think the upper human limit I could
believe ten yeah like I could believe
that if you were really going for it and
you took every aphrodisiac and Viagra
like but like I just 18. no way hey bro
he did a marathon of marathon of jacking
off yeah he did a marathon of
schinderell's like bibliography that's
on average you like you're not at like
one 1.2 hours a day yeah yeah yeah I
think that's crazy how how much if
you're awake right you're awake on
average 16 hours a day that yeah he was
nodding on average every 30 minutes yeah
so uh more than one out more than that
one hour just under it I take more than
now just to recover from them yeah let
alone doing another one absolutely no
one so there's no way yeah
um but only one can take it yeah and I I
genuinely have no idea who's gonna I
don't there are a lot of DeGeneres
there's a lot of degeneracy here uh some
may be less than others I just I just
don't want the MILF Manor to win I don't
want to relive that I I don't want to
relive that yeah that's where degeneracy
has gone too far I'm secretly hoping
that shindo will get the dog I won't be
surprised if Sydney takes this one as
well you think so I think
[Music]
the winner of the most degenerate moment
of the Year Ludwig masturbating 18 times
in one day
that is yeah well I mean on paper that
is just yeah yeah yeah yeah did it went
by a lot yeah I love being one by 37.
37 of the vote loving one because that
is DJing his [__] no sane person
would do it no congratulations Ludwig
yeah do you remember what you jacked off
to Ludwig I'm just curious because that
must have been some like top tier s-tier
[__] Noel
[Music]
he added it on the planet Planet of the
Apes he went like backwards he was like
all right I'm done now he was gonna go
from the 19 here he's like oh that's
planet of the game yeah
it can't be done all right what's the
next the next category oh there's a new
one this is the U.S state we are least
likely to revisit so the reason why
we're putting this new category in is
because for those of you don't know uh
late last year we did a US tour we went
to a bunch of States some new some old
um and uh we I feel like we've got to
experience like pretty much a good
balance of all of The Vibes of the
states of the US even though we didn't
go to all of them yeah uh and so we
decided to have an award for what the
viewers would think out of just the
stories and for everyone who went to the
tour what is the most likely State we're
like we're not going to revisit that was
that was the sentence I made in my head
yeah
uh because uh we did have part of our
show where we did vote uh we did let the
audience vote on which states did they
lease want to be isekai to yes and we
wanted to see if there was a general
Vibe we got on our tour we wanted to see
if the wider order audience would have
the same Vibe as the people who went on
the tour and actual Americans themselves
as well because there was one clear
winner that uh was voted in our live
shows but the categories let's check out
this one were
Florida Ohio Arizona the entire Midwest
why is the entire Midwest here
so who's gonna win one state or 12. Ohio
is in the Middle East
that's like putting out the cigarette
butt on on the orphan you know what I
mean
it's all the categories yeah well um I
have my answer I have my answer as well
okay okay so we all have our answers
because we were on the tour but for the
international audience now for our
International audience the USA
will think we're
we're likely to revisit is
once again congratulations Ohio you have
now won the worldwide award for the
least the state that everyone loves to
clown on the most you won the Nationals
and you won the Internationals now jobs
everywhere how much percentage was that
one
I like the Midwest I just didn't like
Cleveland Ohio yeah no I mean I heard
Columbus is great yeah I don't know if
it is according to people in Ohio yeah
this is Cincinnati's good but Cleveland
was a ghost town yeah yeah yeah I mean I
I have to like the Midwest because I'm
bounds there by [__] like blood and
bond and marriage now so I'm like it
sounds like a year problem Wisconsin
that's that's good that's cool cheese
let's just say this wasn't a shocker
yeah I think we're all expecting this uh
because on tour was the exact same thing
I just honestly I put this award
category in because I just wanted to uh
give Ohio
yeah yeah
just watch VPN you know that Netflix
doesn't show you the entire Library
you know sometimes I want to keep up
with what my friends overseas are
watching but I can't do that one time
because not everything they're watching
is available on Japanese Netflix but
thanks to expressvpn that is the worry
of the past expressvpn lets you change
your online location so you can control
where you want Netflix to think you're
locator they have almost 100 different
server locations so you can gain access
to thousands of new shows plus it works
on other streaming services as well like
BBC iPlayer YouTube and all sometimes
I'm just missing those shows that I grew
up with like Top Gear which I can only
watch on UK Netflix and with expressvpn
it's easy enough to get on that Netflix
all you need to do is open the app
select your location tap one button to
connect and refresh the page to access
the geo-restricted shows you want to
watch it's that easy it's that easy that
easy so be smart stop paying full price
for streaming services and only getting
access to a fraction of their content
get your money's worth at expressvpn.com
Taste don't forget to use our link down
below expressvpn.com trash taste to get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free free free
back to the episode but before we go on
to our next category we actually have a
personal world as well because a big
part of this year we felt like was the
tour right that was a massive part of
the year that was a big reason why we
didn't get a lot of after dark this year
because we were doing after dark IRL
yeah but unfortunately a lot of you guys
probably did not get to experience the
tour you know we have a big
International audience so we wanted to
recount some of our personal favorite
moments that happened on stage in that
moment that not a lot of people might
not know about unless you were at that
specific show yeah so we all have a
personal award that we're going to give
to One Moment in one of the shows yep
draw me to start yeah go ahead Okay so
the moment that stands out to me I want
to give an award to the Chicago show
okay uh because you know Chicago show
was incredible anyway but there was one
moment that I still think back to I like
I as I'm about to go to sleep I think
back to this moment and I just smile
okay uh because part of the show was we
had to defend some of our [__] takes
and uh sometimes we had to defend each
other's take even if we didn't agree
with it and I was up against Joey
and Joey had to uh Joey had to argue
that steak was good
and I had to argue that stake was bad
for an American audience oh yes
and what happened is I go first I go up
on stage and I present my argument Dead
Silence okay now I I knew I knew I I
there was no chance I was I was coming
in with Miguel I had to argue that steak
was [__] to an American audience
presenting my argument I walk off
dejected off stage and I'm like Joey
present your [__] argument Joey had
the biggest guaranteed dub of all time
all he needed to do was to like stick up
for steak and uh we had about 30 seconds
to make an argument Joey walks up he
gets he gets Applause he hasn't even
like started talking they're like I
guess Applause everyone's like whoa and
he goes my fellow Americans
whoa Joey Joey and if he starts talking
about steak and then about 15 seconds in
he starts ranting on about
all all types of stay so good beef steak
pork chop pork steak chicken steak and
I've never seen an audience turn so fast
with just a single line because he went
from like complete cheers to do once
being like what what the f what the [__]
did he say and he's like my fellow
Americans chicken steak am I right pork
steak am I right and then they all were
just
I still see that in my nightmares like
that is like actually the worst thing
I've ever gone to and then they voted
for gone to win and then I won
throws in trash days history that have
been on camera that one unfortunately
wasn't on camera but I think in my eyes
that was the biggest throw anyone has
done in the history of trash it was it
was an absolute you say one thing and
the mood just did after full 180. have
you seen that Meme of like the the DJ
guy like and he's like DJing for a crowd
and he's like you know doing
instrumental break and the crowd's
getting into it and then he goes to the
mic and he goes try to relax your anus
every time I see that Meme I'm like I
get wall flashbacks to that moment where
I said chicken steak and everyone just
went what the [__] what the [__]
try to relax your anus
[Laughter]
you probably would get a louder chair if
you said yeah probably Robin boy you
said [__] me the Chicago show gets my
award for that yeah Chicago show doesn't
get my award for me shocker because of
that uh mine is more like a just a
general I think uh like overall tour
Award of uh just us you know because uh
one of the uh I guess punishments that
we had to do because we had like a
punishment system at the end of each
thing and one that every time we pulled
it uh that the crowd [__] went
Bonkers for
was that one of us had to sing the
American national anthem and I thinking
back on it now when we first got it I
don't remember which one of us got it
first but like you got it first I think
so but like obviously because none of us
are Americans we don't know the [__]
words right so we always had to like get
a phone or get someone's phone or
whatever to look at the lyrics but the
glow up happened where by the end of the
tour like some of us were just able to
sing it off by heart I remember I tried
to go as long as I could without saying
it I think 15 shows yeah yeah and I was
like yes I haven't sung it but then I
finally lost and I got it and I was like
yeah I think I had to sing it like every
like three or four shows by the end of
the tour I I remembered all the lyrics
god I I've never been so uh jealous of
the American patriotism so like it was
the one that sticks out to me the most
was the first one we had to do it which
was the Minnesota show I believe yeah uh
and then oh this was like our second or
third show so we didn't really know what
to expect uh we didn't know what kind of
reaction to expect and I remember one of
us was yeah and uh I remember like
looking down and looking up and everyone
had stood up people people don't in
America they do not [__] around yeah
they were always doing this or this yeah
yeah something yeah people don't really
care that much no yeah that's where you
go really but like I was shocked in like
a casual audience of anime fans yeah but
they all were like all right it's
America time boys yeah yeah yeah yeah
and uh it was just like one of the few
times when I'm like God [__] damn and
I'm like oh this is what you guys rave
on about yeah I get it
man
God I will I will say such a [__]
Banger of national it is I will give it
to them God [__] down it's so fun to
sing yeah yeah yeah what's the
Australian national anthem the
Australian national anthem is like
American but not as high Australia
it's like Australians
it's really fun to sing drunk
we'll give it that but uh it's nowhere
near as powerful patriotic as the
Americans I don't think there's a
national anthem that's as powerful as
the American Wonder sink I can't think
of off the top of my head but even just
singing that you just feel the power
especially when you get when we got to
hold that big American flag just [__]
waving that [__] around I'm just like
yeah like so that I'd say that was the
best moment on the tour for me all right
Connor um I think one standout moment
was um was doing one of the argument
segments and uh it was at the uh
Tennessee show and I had had to defend
my take of music is just music is just
peeps yeah it's gone and gone had like
crushed it it was like the argument was
amazing
it went really well and then it was my
turn and I was just getting booed like
it was like one minute of booing and
then right at the end of it I was like
[__] this I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna piss them off I was like
so I'm ranting and I'm getting all booze
and I go by the way Tennessee country
music [__] sucks and they go yeah
and they just flipped like the whole
crowd went from booing me to cheering
because I thought I thought they loved
country music so I was trying to like
insult them yeah but they loved it they
were like yeah [__] country yeah yeah to
give a little bit of background so
Tennessee is the I believe like the
capital or country music the country
like live music uh not Australia in
America yeah uh and Connor didn't just
get an Applause he got a standing
ovation yeah you know one of the few
standing ovations out of like every show
that we've had that we had until we had
a few but it wasn't like every show it's
like passionately screamed country music
sucks yeah I think so because like
you're like getting booed and you're
like you know what I'm gonna say it
punching music [__] sucks hey wrongly
he said
oh yeah of course they're like anime
fans in Tennessee yeah exactly you know
what I mean like yeah it makes sense but
at the time I was like I think we were
all like what the [__] is happening well
I remember we all looked at each other
like what yeah I was like what is
happening I felt like homelander at the
end of like the last three like kills it
all right well you know I'm like they're
clapping for me this is powerful
there were so many good moments in the
tours yeah it's hard to just pick one
yeah but that's not all because uh we
made some amazing memories in America
this year uh and it was such amazing
memories that we wanted to do it again
so we thought this would be a good time
to announce that we are going back on
tour this year yay this time this time
Europeans we are coming to say hi
welcome say hi guys trash taste Europe
tour 2023 is official guys yes so right
now we don't have the specific dates for
it but we do have the cities that we'll
be going to so we can get you or we can
let you guys know on that right now
cities are as follows I think Dublin
London Cardiff Oslo Copenhagen uh
stalcone Stockholm Berlin yes and
Amsterdam yes yes I think those are all
of them they'll be on the screen as well
so don't worry are we on the screen the
venues are currently being booked right
now that's why we don't have the exact
date but it is going to be starting from
August 30th to around September 13th
that's kind of the date right late I
think one thing we learned from the last
tour is it cannot be as long yeah I
think the other one was too long it was
a lot of fun but it was just a little
like a week or a week and a half too too
much yeah um so we're doing a lot
shorter and obviously we're mainly doing
like North North West Europe yeah it's
not really a European tour but you know
we're going to Europe and uh well
hopefully we'll see some of you guys
then yeah yeah but we'll give you guys
more details in the coming weeks uh
right now tickets aren't on sale
obviously because we're still trying to
finalize everything but you guys uh
we're letting you guys know right now so
you guys can get prepared for it for
when they do go live so yeah my Welsh
boys I'll see you yeah Europeans will
see you there I'm very excited to do a
show in London and fun of all of my
friends and family I um Germans please
please go easy on me please please
go to Germany's I'm taking you to a
Goddamn Bakery it's gonna blow your mind
all right let's move on to the next
award though which is the saltiest
moment I hope I'm not on here there's
probably a lot of them let's go all
right all right uh first one is proceed
after hearing Connor skips cut scenes
and God watches anime two times so I was
I was salty with him when I heard this I
feel like that has a very good shot of
winning it was a very iconic moment I
feel of the trash taste yeah it was just
the sheer disgust it's it's when like
someone who's not familiar with trash
day is just kind of like gets a shocking
Revelation about what the type of [__]
that we talk about you know it's like
you almost forgot what the name of our
show was yes uh God I'm still salty
about the night at a month I'm still
salty about this one the thing that
makes this that makes me so salty about
this one is that I you know if if I was
prepared for like you know second place
if I was prepared for like second place
not being you know having to go to the
manga Cafe then I would be like okay
whatever it was it was in the agreement
you know yeah but the [__] Joe you
have to drag me down with him yeah
because like we actually we didn't have
enough room for one more person in the
five-star hotel yeah yeah and we were
like God if you want to and then Joe was
like you should you should stay in the
morning I think you were also kind of a
little bit intrigued to see what it's
like yeah but also you came to regret it
so yeah yeah yeah it was uh not a good
night's sleep that I got oh sure that
her favorite Hotel it was so overpriced
yeah for what it was that was from the
Japan road trip especially I still have
I still hear the sounds of just the dude
fapping
I just I just I can't I can never unlive
that now
uh then we got Connor losing to gun in
the extreme gamer quiz [__] that wasn't
right that was uh no one expected that
one yeah yeah that was one of the
biggest surprises of the year I did not
expected one time where Connor could
have gone in easy though it was a big
surprise when it's me losing wow you
know what I mean like I'm tired of this
[__] when I win it's not a big surprise
you know this is [__] up you know I've
gone on when you beat me on the anime
quiz you know then then
and then the boys after hearing Emily's
noodle tier list yeah that was pretty
bad that's [__] up that was pretty
[__] uh Sydney losing the wine tasting
special yeah that was a good moment that
was fun actually that that is probably
the saltiest moment yeah yeah I I think
that was the saltiest moment out of
everything this year and then uh Ludwig
not being the biggest YouTuber from a
school which is close though he's very
close I think he actually might have
overtaken him oh really really maybe uh
I mean he's you know that's the only
reason he's continued YouTube just
become the contractual obligation yeah
yeah he's out of the game after that but
yeah they can only be one winner what do
you guys think it'll be Sydney I want I
want I mean Pro CD Sydney I want Pro ZD
to win because also Sydney was the
saltiest so that's it you know all right
let's find out the saltiest moment of
this year's trash taste is
Pro ZD
it was well this is a good song I'm
right there I feel like this was one of
the most discussed moments in a lot of
like our guest episodes
yeah he didn't even like say anything
just just the sign of disappointment
that's all that was needed to be said I
think it started off like that but like
the more the podcast went on and the
more he heard us talk the more you could
see that anger just boiling up and
boiling up you're a voice actor yes I
remember Tim turning to Joe and being
like what are you gonna say whatever
what's what's next Joey what are you
gonna say now and he's like I'm on your
side on your side what was the bro what
was the breakdown on this one
by 43 wow holy [__]
[Music]
let's move on to the next one which is
the most monkey moment I think it's only
fitting that I present this one of
course yeah
why don't you read out the nominee let's
see what we have Connor flooding three
hotel rooms because of TFT
[Music]
yes it's a chocolate biscuit and uh a
Tim Tam slam is when you bite off two
ends of the biscuit and you use it as a
straw to suck up your tea or coffee or
whatever beverage you're having milk
sometimes uh but we myself and the
entire smash audience tricked Sydney
into thinking that a Tim Tam slam was
when you take a packet of tim tams and
you slam it on the ground and then you
open the packet and eat the crumbs she
believed that [__] so much so to the
point where she tried to do it at the
signing that we I had to stop her as the
as as being a good husband everybody
everyone who was there was just like God
how dare you and that's when that was
the exact moment when I realized that
gaslighting foreigners is an Australian
Pastime I don't know how that started
Australians like I was like what's
what's Australian culture people are
just like oh you know it's the wildlife
or the [__] beer no like a true
Australian would just try to Gaslight a
foreigner uh that's the one thing I
found in common with everyone that I've
met in Australia oh yeah absolutely I
fixed my mind uh Connor Segway fall on
the road trip yes well I mean Conor is
one but also gone yeah yeah I think I
broke mine
um this this one is I I this this one
you know the worst part was with that
pad thai wasn't even that good like it
was a pretty bad it wasn't even that
good I thought how could you [__] this
up this is uh simultaneously the like
one of my most monkey moments listening
to and one of my saltiest moments
listening to as well that that was I I
could not I could not believe my soul
left my [__] body because how much is
a pad thai usually it's like three
dollars like two like three dollars is
still like expensive it's like you can
get some for like one dollar one dollar
fifty
um
they paid 20 bucks
I knew we were getting scams but we were
already sat down and I was like okay I'm
like getting scammed in Pad Thai is like
paying seven dollars for Pad Thai all
right
we went through the whole shame on me
shame on me twice we did like five times
like she only five times you got your
bank accounts like completely ripped man
it's it's like helping the economy yeah
man you can't hate on me for that I mean
they're all honestly pretty monkey uh
four of these include Connor yes which
is hilarious four isn't it you're in
this one as well
so either way I'm taking it yeah yeah
Sydney which I have a feeling is not
going to win because uh I mean I I I
think the TFT thing I think it must be
the thing I remember the play-by-play
yeah of getting the message from Connor
because me and Connor were gonna meet up
at the bar and he's like oh I'm gonna be
late I need and he takes me again I'm
gonna be really late and then it was
just like the progression over there I
flooded my room I flooded three rooms
I'm not dead I flooded people think I
flooded my room because I was taking a
bath I was actually just playing TFT it
was just like the evolution of this
story
hey I got Diamond there so I'm still
Diamond to this day all right let's find
out who wins then the winner is
Connor flooding three hotels
I bet it wasn't even close what was it
57 7
that's [__] all second place uh
I have like over like 90 of the votes
yeah well okay got it it's just me I'm
just a monkey you're just a monkey glad
you're gonna be able to retain the title
was it was I win it last year as well of
course yes of course you did yeah glad
to be a returning Champion the monkey
award gotta keep it true yeah Ugg all
right let's look at the next one then
next one is the new one wildest guest
episode yes we did have a lot of guest
episodes this year a lot of them had a
lot of wild moments a lot of crazy
moments a lot of crazy stories uh and we
feel like it would be only be fair to
have some kind of representation of like
all the guests and all the guest moments
that happened this year which is why the
nominations that uh you nominated were
Now red Nigel of course yes we got Pete
Peta yes uh we got the moist man himself
Charlie we got uh Hassan we got Michael
Reeves and we got Pro ZD and we got
shindoel Ludwig and of course Felix a
lot of episodes and that's only like the
tip of the iceberg of the uh actual
guest episode this year and a lot of
them yeah they did have some wild
moments yeah they definitely had some
wild moments I mean Nigel uh that entire
[__] episode I have simultaneously
wiped from my memory but I remember like
the emotions I felt during that episode
I presumed because he was like a science
YouTuber he'd be more reserved yeah he
was so wrong yeah he was off the chance
he's a mad scientist uh Hassan I'm just
happy that we had an anime basically an
anime only episode and it was actually
one of like our most in-depth anime
episodes we've had in the history of
this podcast I think
and then obviously Michael Reeves is
just [__] insane all the time yeah he
brought it to trash days as well uh Pete
just is like the most amazing
Storyteller story no one tells a story
like that and no one has stories like
Pete uh and then of course Charlie is
you know just he finally got to defend
his uh JoJo take to us live in person
and we didn't and uh
this is why talking your feelings out
yeah don't be angry people online just
just get them in the same room and just
have a conversation yeah we honestly got
to see some of his Contraptions as well
oh yeah very very interesting and then
obviously someone who is never coming
back on this podcast because definitely
hates at least yeah I'm surprised he
agreed to do a claw yeah
and obviously shindo making us all open
our third eyes with just the most wild
interpretations of hentai yes uh Ludwig
just because he's Ludwig and uh Felix
because he's Felix yeah yeah I mean the
Felix episode the one of the things that
stood out to me was uh he somehow agreed
with at least one of each of our [__]
takes he he started like he started
neutralizing yeah yeah yeah yeah he
started World War Three and then became
allies with everyone at the same time I
don't know how he managed to do that uh
but that was pretty impressive yeah yeah
who do you think's gonna win though uh I
think it might be between Pete Now red I
think it might be between either I think
those were fan favorites but I think
long-term viewers of trash taste because
you know a lot of the guest episodes get
a lot of viewers from outside
communities yeah yeah but I did notice
that the the trash taste Community loved
those jobs yeah definitely I would say I
mean I I enjoyed recording all of these
all these guys all of these episodes
were like really really fun to enjoy
absolutely to record sorry
um but yeah in terms of like wildest I
would say that now red and Pete had the
craziest stories because they they went
on some side quests in their lives it's
just a man that said yes to everything
for 30 years to 40 Years of his life
yeah it's like all right now I have
enough stories forever yeah for a
lifetime yeah and really and Nar red was
just like let's just try something crazy
yeah I don't have I don't have like a
danger function a number in my brain
we're lucky that now red decided to be a
YouTuber yeah we are not an evil
scientists
Tales of a dangerous scientist who's
grown up doing dangerous experiments but
they can only be one winner
unfortunately and the winner of the
wildest guest episode is
it's no Reds well done congrats Nigel
thank you for not blowing up the earth I
hope you have remembered where you found
that uranium from because I I keep you
happy for another day please don't be
angry yes yes oh yeah I'm sure you know
if we find someone with a meth kind of
like if we find a meth lab in this place
I wouldn't be surprised you know but
whatever just for a YouTube video just
for a YouTube video yeah it's fine yeah
it's a tax write-off all right let's
move on to the next award which is the
best story uh now I mean there's lots of
great stories obviously from us from
guests yeah but they can only be one so
let's look at the nominations we've got
uh Connor fortnite dancing at God's
wedding which is definitely the weirdest
thing I've seen in mind that is a fever
dream uh Pete's voice acting experience
at a Japanese cult I love this story it
just doesn't sound real yeah
uh and then obviously Nigel's uh entire
origin
title there wasn't one that we could pin
down here yeah it's just too much
there's too much there was too much uh
gant's Bird Story I think this is the
one in Thailand yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're just watching like a funny joke
Coming of Age anime
I was like what is that oh it's when Joe
is like a thousand dollars
that's uh that was not my proudest
moment
yeah my dad just walks in he's like what
the [__] is this
losing his rent money
yeah this this one is probably like the
closest one because normally uh for the
last I guess like two years of the best
story was we've always had like a big
between like like one of the three of us
having a big like oh yeah Revelation
about our backstory that no one knew
about and we've never mentioned to each
other a big story like the [__] video
games I guess so it's called a law you
might be following it the god law you
know if you're following that but this
year it's been it's three years you know
a lot about us already so it's just some
wild [__] that happened in other
people's lives yeah honestly yes but
they can only be one winner yeah I don't
know what I actually don't know what's
going to win this one I have no idea
either but the winner of the best story
is
Pete's voice acting experience at a
Japanese call
slow down thumbnail did him dirty
that was an amazing story yeah so funny
and so engaging yeah such a good
Storyteller Amazing Story it definitely
deserves the best story award absolutely
for this year what were the uh what were
the top three though three was Pete's
voice acting experience
holy [__]
dancing
all right good stories good stories all
around well that that's that category
the next one do you know what's Wild
Pete didn't even get for like half of
the stories in his life no no I need two
more episodes yes to cover some ground
holy [__] uh the next award is and one
close to my heart the biggest clown now
of course I've been a champion of this
two times in a row yes so hoping finally
that I don't win at this time because I
don't want this award anymore so the
nominations are as follows Joey what are
these pictures Connor
Aer Lingus gaunt and Chris so I know
which one I want to win oh yes I know
which one I want to win I think the real
question is who comes second all right
because because I think we can all know
who's won this one yeah do we really
know I really hope you guys pause well
there there was one you know one
standout clown this year really went
above and beyond yeah it was and and the
funny thing is that all of this was like
off camera as well but it off camera
became an entire story arc that people
got invested in yeah you know it had its
ups and downs me bullying Air Lingus on
Twitter yeah Reddit was having a field
day with this yeah we get one of the
bags back and it turns out it wasn't the
bag the less expensive equipment and
just as soon as we had lost hope he had
been like nine months you get the email
we get the email and it's like we have
your bag
and we didn't believe it we didn't
believe it I didn't believe it until I
had the physical bag in my hand before I
know it was like someone else's back you
know it was it was it was an empty yeah
someone had stolen all our equipment we
didn't know but uh it was an entire
story arc that had a good ending yeah we
didn't think it did doesn't make it a
Lingus and you're less of a clown though
who do you think's gonna come second
hopefully not me I mean one of uh one of
us in this is wearing the clown costume
so I'm
yeah I I I don't know I feel like uh the
Game of Thrones take
that that produced uh the Game of
Thrones take the light mode take that
produced so much heat on the Reddit that
um I think I might have swayed a few
people I know it's not going to be me
that's for sure all right all right well
let's find out who the winner is and the
winner of biggest clown of 20 no that's
not years it's just
yeah it is congratulations
Above and Beyond in the act of being a
clown as Air Lingus every single
opportunity they fumbled every single
aspect of communication was terrible yes
and every chance they had to redeem
themselves they missed so they are
indeed the biggest clown of this year
how much did they win by though
55.3
yeah so the question is who is second
place
was one company making a Monumental [__]
up for nine months in order to take the
biggest clouds I still had some decent
amount of votes yeah yeah a quarter of
them still voted for you all right gone
what's the next category all right but
the next one the opposite of Clan rate
is of course biggest shot I mean we've
had a lot of hard Chads on the show a
lot of Chad moments a lot of Chads in
the show to like I guess bring that up
as well because we had a lot of guests
this year as well so there were a lot
more nominations this year for biggest
Chad which is why this year's
nominations were Chris oh yeah with the
with the winning the chess boxing it was
pretty Peter
[Applause]
uh we got Joey I look disgusted
we got Hassan who's the only real
picture yeah we got Felix oh look at
that we've got no the Chad burning down
the building and we got shindoell all
right not not bad a very stacked line
everybody very very stats lineup this
year for I mean if we're going by the
definition of the word right okay it's
probably not going to be any of us no
right it's probably gonna be like a tie
between like maybe Felix Hassan maybe
even Chris for winning the chess boxing
he could take it as well take it she's
out of Storytelling yeah sure who knows
honestly this is one of those categories
where I I don't expect anything and I
won't be shocked by anything this is one
of us all right yeah so let's see who
wins this is I have no idea who's going
to win this yeah actually let's find out
though so you guys have voted the
biggest chart in the trash taste Awards
is
[Music]
[Applause]
all right next one is a brand new one as
well we have the biggest W of the year
uh now this is trash taste uh there's
not a lot to choose from but uh let's
have many of those
but uh let's let's see which ones we had
this year we had Conor winning the horse
race and the road trip special I mean
small W yeah sure uh God getting married
that's a big W uh Connor cyclathon also
a Big W airling's bag returned I mean
that's like a is that a double here it's
it's a w considering the entire well
everything that's W on our wallets yeah
it's a w on our wallets and then Chris
winning the chess boxing also a w yeah I
mean there were quite a few W's this
year
um I love I realizing none of these
actually have anything to do with actual
episodes
rather than the special everything is
outside of the scope I
feel like I feel like part of this was a
lot of big things happened off camera
for us as well although I don't think
Chris should win anything for wearing
this Dr jelly shorts those things yeah I
don't excuse you that's my face why do
you look so [__] awful in those
pictures yeah because it's like crispy
it's like crispy I'm gonna say this I'm
real happy that Chris won the chess
boxing but
um him throwing his Queen I still yeah
that was a big ass uh he he went from
like a guaranteed Checkmate to throwing
his Queen I believe and I I remember
screaming at my television uh when that
was it I couldn't I could not believe I
could not believe that honestly I kind
of want to give it to Connor I kind of
like Connor did Connor Connor did
something impressive this year all I did
was say I do now that that was it that
was it that's a w that everyone hopes
and all you can eat free oven baked
pizza that's and you paid for it
and all you can drinking espresso
Martini it is an open bar
we've made God's Wallet work for that
bar poor God all right well out of all
of the W's which one was the biggest one
let's find out the winner of the biggest
W of the year is
God getting married
[Applause]
I did say I did say I do and uh I will
always be known as a grant for the rest
of my life now because I I can't believe
that happened on uh on the most
important moment of my life it should be
wedding times three yeah
three though
thank you thank you very much very much
followed by Honda foreign
with the little W's we have on trash
days we'll take all of them yeah that's
good thank you very much all right but
of course the next category a favorite
of ours the best nickname do we have any
music names this year I feel like I feel
like we didn't but some of our guests
did uh and we had some pretty funny ones
as well and stuff that happened off
camera as well uh so these nominations
are bulge leaves so actually I I joined
the stream I joined your stream like two
days in how did this start do you want
to explain how we were doing smashing
which is you know you just smash it as
you see you've seen it in the movies and
stuff whatever yeah oh my God you're so
strong you can hit an intimate object
hard
um and so I put on an outfit and I guess
my junk was just like enunciated quite
heavily in this junk and it was all chat
could talk about the whole time I was
doing it and it it was the it was a
Bruce Lee outfit so they named me
baldsley and they're just kind of stuck
I guess people loved it and that is just
laughing his ass off the whole time
saying every time I walked out he's like
and I feel like what made this nickname
stick was the fact that he just ended up
breaking the record
you cemented that I couldn't believe
during that moment definitely having
practice with the time we did it I think
helped a lot yeah sure I knew the
technique going in and we last year we
had affable Chris this year we had
haughty Connor yeah uh which is uh I
don't know like I honestly I'd never
heard of this word before you told me
I'd never heard of this word either and
I was like I cannot find a word that
more accurately represents you yeah
that is now permanently ingrained you
can look in the depths of the thesaurus
and there'll be nothing more that
explains it yeah we've got to go through
like all of us now there must be like a
new word to describe all of us every
year so I think so yes and then we also
have uh the greatest uh prank that was
ever pulled
but it makes sense
yeah I don't remember when this was
mentioned but this was mentioned a few
times on the nominations
and I'm like it checks out it checks out
sounds like something I would have said
all right all right so we have four
nominations let's see who's taking it
home come on all right have your votes
placed all right the winner is
Barry chopsticks
sorry I'm surprised this not this didn't
get nominated for best story as well
[Music]
that makes sense
uh moving on to the next one which is
best meme that is awesome uh so as you
know we all we always get some very very
good memes on the Reddit and a lot of
Twitter posts yeah uh so we wanted to
congratulate some people who actually
you know went out of the way and made
great memes out of the episodes and
moments that have happened during the
previous year all right let's check it
out the best memes are Connor streamer
Awards the Connor streamer award memes
there were a bunch of these on on his uh
I'm sorry like there's one I really
liked is when I walk up yeah people meme
to the walk up a bunch and it was like
you know me when I get a triple kill on
fortnite let's go standing up going like
I think I think the reason there's not
one meme of this because this spawned so
many memes in the subreddit but it was
just your pure reaction of just shock
and surprise yeah I didn't expect to win
yeah I was like what the [__] I mean
um where ripped Corner was also a big
thing as well that took over the subway
like I got like 90 000 likes when I
tweeted that picture out Jesus Christ
some people again because it matches so
perfectly with the skin some people
always thought it was real on the first
glance it's real and then you look at it
for a second you're like oh okay but
like for the first glance you're like oh
God whoa you can see where it ends yeah
yeah yeah I'll be honest when I first
saw this pop up into the subreddit
because I didn't get to watch this
stream live I was like oh my God what
the [__] has happened to Connor you got
[__] damn I wish I drink far too much
beer
we've also got uh Dr ligma baby man
this is
the aftermath of the uh the dark
timeline memes that spawns last year
last year I did win last year uh we got
all of the wedding memes as well uh my
favorite of the wedding memes is the uh
Ava parody we did
oh yeah oh just like everyone all the
boys just like
congratulations I gotta thank you for
that Joey because I I always remember
that moment where all the boys were
together for a photo and Joey was like
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
we should do the Ava congratulations
right now and I was like oh my God Joey
you are right you are right it turned
out so well yes and it was it was
literally a once in a lifetime
opportunity so thank you very much to my
boy reminded me of that uh when Conor
has an opinion
my my favorite one of when Connor has an
opinion is when uh I think it was a year
or two ago of the slow motion footage of
me and uh just like looking towards the
camera there's so many variations
variations uh we got how these two look
at each other whenever they be I don't
remember
who is she
only [__] that's such a good answer such
a good edit
that's so good holy [__] uh we got uh
the level of disappointment in Pro zd's
eyes yeah that's uh that's pretty much
how that episode went yeah
I don't even know about this one dude
yeah it was right this is popped off I
remember seeing a dying right it was
yeah it's got 11 000 uploads yeah
yeah
oh God I [__] hate Twitter
yeah I just found out I got raped 11
000 likes of Joey getting ratio uh Gone
0.1 seconds after getting married to an
American
okay
[Music]
the one with Corner screaming is my
favorite show I think
oh
this is
way too well edited oh my God there's
just so much [__] this is so good
oh bro oh
it's your boy Chris very nice very good
meme there's also the trash taste anime
intro yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
that's so good
[Music]
what the [__] holy [__] oh none of us
seen this
oh my God
[Music]
what the [__]
oh my God
you guys have way too much this is
incredible
holy [__]
[Music]
this is uh what we should have used this
as the intro for the trash case Awards
this year yeah right this literally
crazy yeah
what the actual phone
[Music]
oh my God it went hard went hard
yeah I was gonna say uh I think what I
like about the trash days after dark was
it was such a good meme that it kind of
like I I see that as the end of the
after dark meme kind of like timeline
yeah I think everything kind of like
tapered off after this meme was posted I
think so anime intro I don't know I do
not know how I missed this one because
that what did I miss that [__]
incredible well damn but they can only
be one winner ladies and gentlemen today
yes what is it
there were a lot of nominations this
year so many so many good memes and uh
so many good memes we just watched right
now fresh but the best meme of the trash
taste Awards this year goes to
the dark timeline trailer
honestly I am I'm surprised it won yeah
yeah I thought people wouldn't have the
patience to sit there one minute 30
videos
sure
either the dark timeline trailer won by
26.8 okay okay followed by when Connor
has an opinion
no no fair enough fair enough and
Rubicon over 10% all right checks out oh
yeah those uh did take over the
subreddits sure sure I wanna I wanna
give more Awards to the anime opening
yeah that was awesome I think it's a
personal award yeah yeah you get the
personal award from us what the [__] all
right what's up next all right well next
one is a brand new one as well we have
the best Deez Nuts moment because uh as
I said at the beginning there was a kind
of a Renaissance of Deez Nuts jokes
among uh trash taste yeah and it kind of
spread throughout yeah so I think the
started from the charity stream when I
got these nuts about 36 million times uh
and a big part of this year was us
traveling to conventions and getting to
interact with you guys and what we
realized after interacting with you guys
is that you guys just love to Deez Nuts
us you're all children yeah it was like
it was like a competition about who
could wind up with getting the best Deez
Nuts moment on the boys I swear there
was a moment for for a brief moment
where among the the trash stays fan base
where it was like it was kind of like a
badge of honor if you were like yeah I I
Deez Nuts God IRL and I was like whoa
holy [__] he did it but yeah there were
a lot of Deez Nuts uh so let's go
through all of them yeah so so we have
we have the truck and these nuts what
happened at ax to Connor which anime
protagonist has the power sneak thieves
I don't watch enough I don't know this
one
oh my God
[Applause]
is that even a good one is it even a
good one sneak these nuts not to mention
that like Mouse like kind of said it
before yeah yeah Mouse knew it was
coming Connor was like oh I don't know
what's going on man next one is my
personal favorite uh my load on your
face which isn't technically a Deez Nuts
but uh this one was a new one for us I
guess these nuts is more of the Cadence
yeah
last question today
um from Jaden do you know what Milo is
n't it like most Southeastern countries
yeah
uh I mean it's pretty popular in
Thailand yeah yeah
do you know what it is
four it's a chocolate chocolate well
there's the second part uh to this
answer it says yeah my load in your face
[Applause]
I love the way the MC says it as well
she was committed to it he just says a
soul I think nonchalantly I think what
makes it stand out in my mind so much
was that we just had an entire
conversation taking it seriously it
wasn't a quick one it was just the oh
yeah I know Milo I and we just had a
full-on [__] conversation about it
didn't expect it I did not expect that
at all and uh that was that was
incredible uh with next one is uh
probably the most recent one which is uh
Kawaii Khan Deez Nuts
um villain I don't know
[Music]
Paul Connor you like me
[Applause]
there's just the the the Vigor of which
he said it is so intense
you know sometimes you have to say these
nuts joke in all caps respect to this
guy because this guy set the tone for
this panel yeah everyone wasn't playing
he was the first one yeah he was the
first question that was asked yeah she
came to us later and nailed everything
like you said like the Bangkok name yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the
man was very talented yeah and uh this
one is one of our own getting uh this is
when we least expected it have you tried
these nuts
[Applause]
why is it always me why am I always the
one people are asking these questions to
none of these moments are my favorite
all of them suck none of them should win
I personally just want to give it to
rock on just because Kevin just no one
was expecting it and Kevin just nailed
it I thought I was safe I trusted you
Kevin you were in the circle of trust
now you are out of this never trust
Australians that's the rule of thumb uh
Australians man but uh yeah all all
really good nominations uh and some had
some different buildups I I gotta either
give it to uh Kevin or Milo yeah because
Milo I literally did not see that one
coming I think the trucking One's Gonna
Win there you think so it's it was the
one that was shared the most oh [__] all
right let's find out
is
Kraken
oh all right I mean
he did uh he did start the uh Trend it
was just because it was like the room
was like a 1 000 capacity Filled Room it
was like intense and yeah it was just a
it was a it was a lot yeah yeah
all right uh what were the top two
nine points oh [__] yeah see I told you
guys okay
all second followed by my load on your
face
that was a long build up for that one
yeah that's what made it so good yeah
it's the payoff the payoff made it worth
well let's hope we don't have enough for
this category next year all right uh
because I don't want to get these nuts
okay now we are we are aware guys so
next time we go to a convention we're
looking out we've got to work extra hard
you've got to work extra hard if you
want to get us next time the next award
is a classic the best drip Awards who
will win the best trip I mean we had so
many guests who just came in with the
drip as well so I think there's going to
be a new guests to nominate well I'm not
sure about that but let's look at the
nomination shall we Connor Connor that's
me with the suit yeah Joey the one time
Conor's not wearing uh the uh
Joey gone Miss soccer look yeah yes not
sure about that Anthony yeah
all right that's the nomination some
tough competitions look at that you
can't beat the energy from one picture I
think is strong enough that it could
take it I want to take it yeah I like
how my dad's never been on any four
content aside from like one aside from
one picture that just got posted online
or some [__] the hat takes a lot of
confidence yeah yeah only your dad can
rock off that I'll be honest when I when
he first started wearing that uh because
he first started like wearing that uh in
like my teenage years I was like Dad Dad
are you gonna really wear Fedora come on
dad really but like now that now that
I've grown up
with the suit it wasn't sent yeah I
remember this picture just getting
shared all over the Reddit so that
that's not what I was expecting but who
will it be who is the best strip
hopefully it's not Chris ladies and
gentlemen the winner of best strip 2023
is
dance
congratulations Dad let's go you
probably don't even know you got
nominated
you probably didn't even know the
internet were talking about you Dad but
uh congratulations
yeah everyone was talking about your dad
one picture and uh you want best uh who
was the top three
oh my God
55 oh [__] God followed by Chris with
14.5 wow
what what where's the suit once
I'm just gonna stop wearing suits yeah
all right well that was best drip well
deserved congratulations God stat uh
Gone what's the next category the next
category is we awarded best trip of
course we have to oh no laziest oh no as
well all right lazy strip and the
laziest trip nominations ah Connor
understandable Joey
me yes and Chris is that it
as much as I do think Connor has the
laziest rip I kind of want Chris no
Chris has even lazier drip yeah I'd say
Chris is Lazy Love meme me but Christmas
wears polo shirts all black t-shirts
yeah that's all he wears yeah I mean uh
Chris hasn't won an award uh this year
yet so you gotta give him a dog we gotta
give him a dub right but there can only
be one winner out of the four of us
let's find out and the winner for
laziest trip goes to
Connor
don't worry Connor this year I'll I'll
change you
then I went by a lot yeah
52. so at least tell me Chris got a
second
yeah
I'm lazy it's called consistent there's
a difference okay lazy would be putting
no effort I put a lot of effort into
making sure I wear the same thing I put
a lot of effort into buying the same
shirts yeah I do I do all right well
thank you all right
congratulations sure thanks let's move
on though to the next one which is uh
Pinnacle of trash days the best argument
yes lots of arguments this year as
always on traffic I always have
arguments let's look back on some of our
best arguments shall we so we have again
live mode versus dark mode that was uh
that wasn't even an argument that was
just a beating if I'm being honest I
mean uh it was me versus the worlds uh
and I and and you lost
and once again it was both the top ones
just me versus the world what the Game
of Thrones finale what the [__] guys
some of the returning hot takes from
earlier Attack on Titan is a macro anime
from Joey Charlie prefers earlier JoJo
parts that was kind of that's an
argument that expanded across years yeah
it finally got resolved it finally got
resolved in this one one piece being
political which is true this is true and
the rice versus bread argument oh I've
also got Sydney and Connor arguing about
wine which is just like it's not even a
trash tasting that's just the daily
thing yeah and uh Fearless agreeing with
all the boys bad takes
what what did he agree with it again I
know he agreed with me on not watching
Arcane he agreed with you on I think
skipping cutscenes yeah uh skipping
cutscenes in video games yeah and he
agreed with you on cutting off the crust
of a pizza oh yeah yeah yeah we saw him
do that I was like that's actually
[__] yeah it was [__] up literally
cut out I finally found a fellow cross
lover and then he had to agree with
Connor on uh skipping cut scenes and I
was like is he smart
and he didn't watch Arcane because he's
smart no that's bad uh so who do you
think's gonna win
awesome it's hard this is actually a
really tough one yeah I do think one of
guards ticks might take it though I'm
secretly hoping light mode versus dark
mode gets two dogs
versus Brad could also be up there yeah
sure I think the uh Attack on Titan is a
Mecca anime could also be up there that
was a pretty [__] heated argument
that got Joey to say that Mac uh that
Abra is what I'm making around me stop
reminding me out of like the Heat of the
Moment which I'm just like oh no I don't
know I don't know what that came from
don't make me eat my words do you know
how I know like you know how I know it's
a good argument when we get heated
enough to say something really [__]
that's how most of our [__] tastes come
from we just get so heated we just we
just say a really really shitty too
that's true so they can only be one
winner only one yes only one let's find
out the winner of the best argument of
the year goes to
attack on titanism
thanks
wow I'm shocked at one honestly well
what did you think was gonna win I
thought it could have been one of God's
spicy takes sure Hills he was dying on
were not worth it
that was close he was agreeing with all
the boys bad takes cool 17 points wow
so it was in the running
yeah I'd say shock this one honestly but
it was a great argument one of the best
ones we've had yeah it was fun to see
Joey say something just could find out
it was like Instant Karma compilation
doesn't have samurais in it
all right let's move on to the next one
Connor what is it the next category is
the most wholesome moment Awards I think
we've had plenty of holes yeah yeah I
mean I feel like this year just because
we've been traveling so much and a lot
of us have been doing a lot of stuff off
camera that just ended up being a trash
station and ended up being a lot more
wholesome than I guess we're used to
yeah we thought we had that's why I had
to do that hentai episode really like
you know kind of even it out pull
everyone back down yeah you know a lot
of a lot of trash taste is us arguing
and shouting with each other but you
know at the end of the day we're still
friends people can forget that sometimes
moments this year let's check out the
nominations though yes so we have um
this one is wholesome because we didn't
know we were being recorded we did this
was such a kid can you play this one in
the video this might be my favorite
video it's very awesome
[Music]
visceral memory of this hug it was just
like I don't know because this was like
the first song dad comes back from
getting the milk
yeah
do you know how do you know how no this
is wholesome this is so wholesome that
it didn't get memed at all just people
just posted the clips without like
caption or anything I did it sure Connor
was the first one to me man but Emily
bringing the boys fruit gifts yeah which
was very wholesome because we didn't
know this was happening this this was
tough because uh we were we brought
Emily on to like destroy her for her
food takes and she comes on and like
disarms us and we're like Emily what the
[__] man how can you do something so
wholesome this is made it ten times
harder to roast you yeah yeah exactly uh
we got both story as we mentioned
earlier awesome we got Connor completing
the cycle it's very wholesome for one of
the clips I guess sorry
God uh the end of Kevin's episode where
he almost cried oh that was a cute one
bro
yeah we had a big group hugs yeah oh you
know I I feel like what makes that so
wholesome is that people forget now or
people haven't forgotten but it feels
like it's been such a long time since
the World opened up again we got to
travel and people had been stuck in
their homes for two years yeah and just
having Kevin just kind of be like hey
guys I missed you guys helped me through
a bad time and I'm just like [__] man
yeah what a bro and then we got [__]
faced that night yeah we got absolutely
[__] shit-faced uh honestly all of
these could win I'm happy with any of
these winnings
any of them deserve it and they're all
all great memories I think we all share
absolutely but there can only be one let
us know pull some
and the award goes too
Don and Joey hugging
he's very wholesome very wholesome very
wholesome this is this is going to be
one of those videos I'm gonna look back
on in like 30 Years and [__] cry you
know you know what I mean like the good
old days man I felt like watching the
end of an anime yeah yeah it did
it's like they did it they [__] did
it oh hell yeah thank you guys thank you
very much what was the top thriller
chunk
s
yeah hell yeah I mean that was very very
wholesome indeed appreciate it
appreciate it
at the end of the cabinet service yeah
yeah that's yeah all right I'm glad the
campaign yeah because that definitely
such a good moment so very nice moments
thank you guys uh now we're going the
opposite direction I wouldn't say the
opposite of wholesome but uh you know uh
we like to talk about a lot of our
problems here on trash days some of them
are genuine problems some of them are
the most [__] first world problems
you could ever imagine uh what you're
talking about I don't know I don't I
don't know
because
next moment is the most privileged
moment of War there's plenty of those
Greatest Hits yes yes you know we I did
we have this in the first Trash taste
the wall yeah we added it in the second
one we added in the second one so we
didn't know trustees would blow up
we just got progressively more
privileged everything what can we say
guys uh we're not relatable anymore you
know this time we fell off and this
award proves it because the most
privileged moments of this year were
gone having three weddings okay that's
very privileged that is that is very
very privileged uh
when did you do this oh this was in LA
This was oh yeah because they wouldn't
give him a beer yeah they wouldn't give
me a beer and I had to like literally
bring out my famous birthdays at my
Wikipedia page uh as ID to try and buy a
[__] way it's such a flex it's such a
flex uh I'm not poor Sydney
all right keep saying that Zuni yes uh
Joey getting Chad and Ludwig into a bar
in Australia oh that was in Sydney yeah
yeah manager recognize me yeah Felix
getting a private jet for his dog that's
privilege and Connor's coffee machine
why is my coffee machine on here I mean
because how much did you spend on that
[__] coffee machine it's only two
Grands bruh hey hey it's worth it now
she knows it was two grand that's not
privilege listen this [__] coffee
machine I I even if I've already traded
my firstborn son like eight times
already on this podcast I'm trading them
again for another one I'm bringing him
back and then training him again I I
don't think I've ever spent this much
money on something that also gave me 10
times the amount of Joy back I would
have paid more honestly
it's so goddamn good that machine I love
it but uh out of all of these absolute
privileged moments they can only be one
winner It's gotta be it's got to be the
three-way It's gotta be it's got to be
the three right It's gotta be it's gotta
be there it's not I'm gonna cry so
balance out the most wholesome moment
yeah it's gonna be the three wordings
let them know let them know go on all
right and the winner of the most
privileged of moments of trash taste
goes to
Felix getting a private jet for his dog
I think on the grand scale of things
this is probably nice I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna call it right now
uh I don't think this was his most
privileged moment well what was his
privilege moment oh yeah I think that's
the most privileged Felix might I think
you know
private jet for his dog you know his you
know his dog I get that if I was in
Felix's shoes I would do exactly the
same thing you know
um never been to Greg's yeah that was
yeah I've been living in England that
was crazy to me that that I have never
heard privilege in one line until I
heard Felix say that man
yeah that you know getting a private jet
for your dog I understand I agree you
know I've never been to Greg's Felix
what the [__] man what the [__] you were
living in England for how many years
that's crazy imagine having a loving
wife who makes sandwiches for you like
that's just you disgusting
I've been to the UK twice and I've been
to Greece what came second to Third
second was God having three ways yeah
okay
[Music]
well deserved
moments all Great Moments all right
let's move on to the next one which I
think again is just a pinnacle of trash
taste because uh you know trash days is
definitely not a podcast where you come
uh
[Music]
where you come to hear a bunch of men
talking about very well researched
things yeah so yeah this is the perfect
award for that we don't have nuanced
opinions no of course not we definitely
do our research we just say [__] so we
have the I made it the [__] up award
which just explains itself really uh so
let's uh look at the nominations
Aristotle inventive thinking
that whole episode was a [__] fever
dream did I say this I think you said
that yeah
I'm not happy about that I love the fact
that the thumbnail just has you with
like
well you're really haughty it's a
perfect thumbnail uh we have Hunter
Hunter getting canceled yeah this uh I
remember this kind of like blew up on on
the Reddit because I remember we
recorded a few episodes in a row and I
think we just all misread the news and
we're like Hunter Hunter got canceled
and it has it hasn't actually no cancel
just on Hiatus again yeah yeah bro it's
never it may as well be canceled it is
never getting made yeah it is never
getting made and I I believe it's
getting moved over or something I
haven't actually read the news article
in a while so I can't call him over
there's not going to be any [__]
chapters you know what I'm okay I'll be
honest I'm making [__] up as I go along
now I don't actually know why I kept my
mouth shut because I don't want this
moment to be in next year's award I'm
just saying [__] I can't actually
remember the news article uh but uh all
I know is that it wasn't canceled no
yeah it may as well be it might as well
be uh 60 hertz monitor is the same as
this is such a dog [__] that's not even
like an eye made of the [__] up that's
just my opinion yeah I think that is I
made it the [__] up because there is a
difference okay I guess so there is no
there is no reason it's the same Michael
Reeves boxing coach telling him he can't
not all right
because he could smell it apparently if
you did I don't know what that means I
suppose so I don't know uh Crystal and
Connor he booked under Barry Johnson
yeah I guess this came under them I made
it the [__] up I mean he made the name
the [__] up yes
I remember being kicking and Confused
between logarithmic and exponential
exponential and I believe we both made
some points that were accurate and some
points that were completely inaccurate
yeah and we were just it was like the
dumbest argument on trash days because
there was two Engineers arguing for
something that they studied in their
degree and neither of them got it got it
completely right
right
it means anything yeah his name or is
that it okay that's it all right it's
got to be either Aristotle it's got to
be the Aristotle I just love the
Aristotle thing at that entire I
remember this episode that entire
episode
I can also see uh Barry Chopsticks yeah
yeah see that as well sure yeah maybe
the anime fans will come through for the
hunter got canceled takers yes we'll see
which one one let's find out shall we
the winner of the biggest I made it the
[__] up award goes to
Chris telling Connor he booked on the
Barry Chopsticks well done we didn't
make it the [__] up damn Barry Sean
sticks with the two doves this year bro
holy [__] what were the breakdowns I'm
curious
okay
robots it was 18.2 percent that was
close yard and that dude
[Music]
don't trust me all right let's see let's
go on to the uh second or last one I
think yeah second the last award this
one is you know obviously we didn't have
as many After Dark episodes this year
yeah but we still had enough to be able
to do this category yeah we'd like to
know what you guys thought was the
strongest episode so this next award is
the best trash taste after dark episode
or moments this episode here
so this is the best trash taste after
dark moment all right let's go through
all right uh the boys handling animals
in Australia my favorite one of that is
when I think what was it it was the baby
crocodile or like the uh the lizard or
something was just freaking out in your
hand yeah they did not like being in my
hand yeah that was such a good episode
though I remember this this screenshot
of me just petting that lizard you'll
spread around on the Reddit to be like
yes
take over the world
to worry
uh we got everyone not getting the Among
Us sounds in the game of quiz yeah but I
think the one that got clipped a lot was
uh all three of us going it's so
mostly all at the same time uh Gone
winning the game of quiz you mentioned
that earlier yeah uh God accidentally
opens up a cultured book oh yeah oh I
have to stop you from showing that on
the stream
uh we got gone spending ten dollars
instead of a hundred dollars on the
Christmas special this was uh I feel
like this was a personal favorite of
mine because uh the last Challenge on
the uh Christmas special I feel like
epitomizes trash taste in a nutshell so
yeah we had a challenge to buy presents
for each other yeah and we had a hundred
dollars to buy presents for each other
and uh we all did uh something different
for this challenge because Joey followed
the rules I mistakenly
um stuck a hundred dollars for ten
dollars
and Connor uh completely forgot about
this Challenge and just brought [__]
from his house
which I feel epitomizes each of our
personalities
I give you guys again I don't even
[__] remember I probably threw it out
I gave you a kiddie pool yeah you gave
me a kitty pool which I took back what
did you give me I don't remember what I
gave me I don't know
oh yeah oh he's an English manga oh yeah
which I already had yeah yeah that's a
good gift and Joey actually uh tried and
like thought long and hard yeah yes that
he gave each other unbelievable yeah and
then uh last one is everyone gets drunk
in the wine stream that was my favorite
after dark stream oh yeah that was the
one where the uh John Perry the third
and the stream [__] destroying itself
even like everyone got drunk including
the sets that was crazy Jesus Christ
yeah great episode but they can only be
one winner what was the best moment of
the after dark episode
voted by you at home and the winner is
drum roll please
everyone gets drunk in the wine
yeah that was my favorite I do think
that was a very very good episode just
involve alcohol and going on live just
we should get [__] faces just being smug
and beating Sydney it was just such a
good combination of it was just great it
was I'm so happy it was like drunk
energy as well
they they got a they got a screenshot
all right all right yeah what was the
top three so everyone gets drunk in the
wine street with 18.2 oh it's actually
quite close that's very close Okay in
second place the boys handling animals
in Australia oh that was a very fun it
was very close that was fun yeah
well glad to know you enjoyed those
moments but we have one award left isn't
that right gone yes we have one final
award which is the best trash taste
episode of the Year God how do you
decide yeah I don't know
um I mean the hardest part uh of this is
that I can barely remember all the
episodes of the year so I don't know how
you guys ended up voting on it
yourselves uh but there were a lot of
memorable episodes this year a lot of
different guest episodes that were very
very memorable which is why we decided
to include it this year
um and uh yeah should we get to the
nomination let's find out best trash
taste episodes this year so we have
episode 120 Nile red episode 111 Pro ZD
episode 137 Pete episode 123 shower
thoughts which is the first non-guest
episode uh episode 124 Paul Felix
episode 127 Charlie episode 145 Hassan
episode 114 Ludwig episode 101 Emily
that was the first of this year uh the
second hand type so 144 the road trip
special and our boy got married episode
107. so it's kind of all over the board
yeah wholesome episodes a lot of guest
episodes obviously because they're very
diverse but uh some good triple trash
taste ones in there yeah I mean I I
personally just want to give it to
the special but like I don't know uh
yeah it's kind of tough really I mean
all of these I wouldn't be mad yeah yeah
all of them I had a lot of fun filming
that's why they got nominated uh
I feel the road trip special turned out
pretty well as well uh but it took so
much [__] time and effort
but uh that we only ended up releasing
one special this year right yeah I think
so yeah only one special which we said
we're gonna do more and we didn't yeah
so sorry
honestly yeah I'm okay with any of these
winning they're all [__] amazing
episodes
um
no
no yeah I don't know which one really to
win it's it's all good memories uh but
there can only be one winner for what
you guys voted as the best episode this
year to cap off to cap off this third
year of trash taste all right here we go
which is why the winner
for the best trash taste episode in I
guess season three yeah season three of
trash taste is
it's just a testament to Pete's
character and being able to tell a story
that's engaging yeah a lot of people
weren't familiar with Pete when they
went into the episode yeah and I think
they left feeling really engaged and
really fascinated by a very talented
Storyteller yeah I mean I think quality
speaks for itself because when we first
release the episode uh going into like
the analytics the Pete episode performed
pretty like average or even like maybe
below average just because a lot of
people didn't know P back then yeah and
uh it's soon over time turned out to be
one of the most successful episodes I
think it's got over two million views
now wow yeah yeah yeah which is just
crazy which is just a testament to the
quality of the episode itself so
congratulations congratulations
[Music]
yeah yeah and uh thank you guys for
tuning in to the annual trash taste
Awards um and thank you for another
[__] amazing year of trash day yeah
it's been a great year the fact that
we're able to do this for 150 episodes
and you guys are still loving it still
coming back every week it makes us just
super [__] happy yeah so we
appreciate you guys so much and uh on to
season four right into season four yeah
I think the big thing this year I will
always remember is this is the year that
we got to like interact with you guys
for the first time after just being
through a screen and just seeing
comments and seeing the Reddit post this
was the year that we actually got to
meet you guys shake you guys hand put
maybe even perform in front of you guys
uh and it was a [__] incredible
feeling and we hope to do more exciting
things in the coming year some of which
we've already announced the tour yeah we
are very excited to go meet our Euro
Bros keep your eyes out on that guy and
um I know we talk about this every year
but specials but we've we actually have
already some in the backlog so yeah do
not worry about that uh with that there
will definitely be more specials this
year yeah I mean I think for us it was
the specials we're just trying to get a
better way of making them because right
now although all the other specials just
us making them yeah and the problem is
is that we all do our own things yeah we
also struggle to just keep up with trash
taste in general yeah so you know we're
trying to we're trying to try some new
stuff out maybe bring more people on
board to try and help the process so we
want to get to the point where trashy
specials are more frequent and hopefully
higher quality yeah uh so we're working
on that uh it's we're not just doing
nothing stuff is coming yeah and of
course it's all a big uh thanks to you
guys who support us on the patreon as
well guys if you guys weren't supporting
us ever on the patreon over there we
wouldn't be able to do half the things
that we do so we super [__]
appreciate you guys for sticking to the
patreon and uh speaking of which look at
all of them here they are look at all
these patreons right here look at all
these beautiful patreons
they all deserve an award exactly let's
let's do a round of applause for the
patrons
if you guys would like to join us and
support us for season four of trash
taste then head on over to our patreon
patreon.com trashtaste also as always
follow us on Twitter send us your memes
on the subreddit and if you had our face
listen to us on Spotify and uh thank you
for another 50 episodes uh we hope to go
for [__] it's gonna be episode 200 the
next it's episode
200. oh my God yeah episode
that's so much content but before that
we have a full year of awesome content
for you guys coming up and uh we hope to
see you guys there yeah so we'll see you
guys next week
uh
[Music]